it's great to welcome to the program
today bill Eddie who is the co-founder
and training director of the
high-conflict Institute also author of
the book why we elect narcissists and
sociopaths and how we can stop so first
of all thanks for joining me bill
my pleasure David I'm glad to be honest
so I think that the question of why we
elect them is a good one but I think a
precursor to that is why are so many
more of our choices than would be likely
given their prevalence in the general
population one that maybe should be
addressed first I mean is there
something to the idea that those who end
up in positions of power in politics and
arguably in corporations are more likely
to be narcissistic and sociopathic well
I think slightly greater chance in
general because these are personalities
that are attracted to being in positions
of power positions where they're above
other people seen as superior to people
etc but the more recent years last you
know 10 15 years we're getting a lot
more of these folks and more extreme
ones because they've realized that
especially in politics you don't have to
have any experience as long as you're
good at attracting attention
dramatic telling people things are
terrible you've got to have me as a hero
that seeming to be increasing right say
in the last 10 10 to 15 years yeah I
mean it seems that to some degree I mean
even if I think about myself right to
even think that someone might want to
watch a show that I host there has to be
some degree of what we could call
anything from confidence to arrogance
all the way up to and including
narcissism and this would apply to many
fields if you think you are the right
person to lead a country of 340 million
people there are certain personality
traits that I imagine would be would
have to be there but it seems like the
issue is when it crosses a certain line
and starts to become problematic in the
ways that you describe
yes and crossing that line is the
problem because you're right confidence
is good a teeny bit of arrogance perhaps
but not much because then it becomes
dysfunctional and what we're looking at
with narcissists and sociopaths really
is dysfunctional behavior and when they
cross the line they basically don't
learn don't change don't have empathy
don't have remorse don't care about
other people are so absorbed in
themselves their own power their own
image that they actually can become
quite dangerous
can you talk specifically about the ways
that you see those characteristics as
potentially becoming dangerous when they
are held by or part of the makeup of
world leaders like presidents of
countries and what practical ways I mean
is it starting Wars that shouldn't be
started is it you know we can think of
policy but in the bigger sense what is
the danger well the danger is that they
have the ones that are problematic or
what I call HCPs high conflict
personalities with four character traits
the first one being a preoccupation with
blaming others and because of that they
target other people and they don't look
at themselves and if they're narcissists
sociopaths and high conflict people then
they're gonna target people and in many
ways harm those people and especially
for sociopaths possibly destroy killed
individuals or large groups of people so
it's that emphasis on targeting people
that makes them so dangerous and it's a
psychological phenomenon because they're
really diverting from themselves they
can't see anything they've ever done
wrong and with other people they always
see their superior or wanna dominate so
the danger comes in if they have a high
conflict personality as well as
narcissistic and sociopathic traits so
bill I mean you you are part of the
conflict institute you are a licensed
clinical social worker that works
providing therapy to people of all ages
you have worked in a number of different
settings where you work with an observed
people that have these traits to
different degrees when you look at the
current President Donald Trump what if
anything matches what you would consider
narcissism what if anything sociopathy
well first of all I do believe he has
the high-conflict personality fixation
on blaming other people narcissistic
traits and by the way because I'm a
clinical social worker licensed to
diagnose mental disorders I'm not
supposed to diagnose people I haven't
met so I'm not going to say whether or
not I think he has a personality
disorder true but I can say that he has
some traits and the narcissistic traits
I think most people in the world today
realize he's preoccupied with himself he
demands admiration he has grandiose
ideas with no basis for them he does
seem to lack empathy he gets in trouble
all the time for hurting people
in his policies and in his comments he
doesn't care and his goal is to be seen
as the most superior person in the world
so he's always stepping on people to get
higher and higher and he he pushes
people around for that sociopathic
traits are being highly aggressive and
that's what we see that's part of why
these folks succeed so he has highly
aggressive behavior he's willing to take
risks that everyone's shocked at and
then he gets away with it and even he is
surprised but also deceitful lying and
conning these are traits of sociopaths
and he seems to you know someone
recently reported something like 10,000
lives since he took office
conning even before he became president
and he he did an interview I think on
the radio where he pretended he was
somebody else
recommending Donald Trump so those
characteristics but also a lack of
horse and drive to dominate other people
and and that's what we see with these
leaders around the world they want to
move people around they want to you know
divide people put up walls and fences
and cages and and and they like the
power to really make people do things
that they don't want to do when it comes
to those who vote for these folks what
is it about these personality sort of
packages that are appealing to at least
enough voters that folks like Trump win
elections in many different countries
yeah and what we see all over the world
really is the same pattern part of it is
their ability to communicate ten times
more than everybody else and at an
emotional level which really gets under
the surface under your conscious
thinking explain that when you say they
communicate ten times more you are you
saying they communicate ten times more
information ten times more often so they
sing ten times as many words as the next
close closest candidate or politician
does they are always talking in Europe I
forget which one it was
give three speeches a day and we see in
the US especially the use of Twitter and
such is there's constant messaging
coming from this type of leader and most
politicians historically are busy you
know behind the scenes you know making
things happen working on legislation
this and that but the leaders you see
today are communicating to the public
intimately in their homes in their hands
and for the last hundred years
electronic media has made that possible
radio first then television Facebook
Twitter all of this in the Philippines
they say that Facebook really made the
election there they call it ground zero
for the fake news and really
manipulating people but it's a constant
barrage of messaging
you won't see other politicians doing
that so you've got the HCPs up here and
everybody else talks to the public maybe
once a week they make a policy
announcement or something but this
person is constantly talking in
emotional terms and they're
communicating what I call the fantasy
crisis triad which is there's a terrible
crisis and there's an evil villain
calling causing the crisis a group or
person and I'm the hero and so I'm gonna
save you from this terrible crisis and
from this evil person or persons yeah I
mean we saw that almost literally during
Trump's campaign when he would identify
problems and actually say only I can fix
this
yes exactly and that's the classic line
of hcp leaders because they have to come
in as a hero because if they run for
office based on their experience their
skills their knowledge they don't have
experience skills and knowledge in
government and politics so they always
come in as an outsider claiming to be a
hero and to have that they have to have
a crisis that's usually a fantasy or
they create a crisis which could
actually be real and then get into power
with that so people have to learn that
pattern that's a lot of what I'm trying
to teach with my book so I want to be
careful here in what I say because this
can get sort of dicey but there seemed
to be similarities in that particular I
mean listen all politicians want us to
believe that they know what the problems
are and that they have the solutions to
the problem to some degree but you're
talking about something that goes a
little bit beyond that and I have seen
that in studying Mao in studying Chavez
and Maduro and Venezuela Putin Stalin I
you have to be careful when you say it
Hitler to some degree there was this
idea of exaggerating the degree to which
the problem is narrowly sourced and then
making the case that you are the
uniquely qualified person to fix that
problem which in and of itself is more
or less a fantasy exactly and and that
pattern
people say well you
compared people to maids a Hitler but
there's a pattern of behavior that they
all share in many ways I see Hitler
Stalin Mao Zedong as the originals they
kind of established the pattern and that
people today are still using that no
they're not the same people many ways
they're very different but one thing
that's similar is their extreme they
could be on the left or on the right and
that's what we're seeing is it's not
about politics it's about the
personality and how they think they can
get a route to power well that's true he
was where I think it does become
political bill which is while
politicians on the left and right can
have these personality types traits and
behave in this way a lot of studies that
we've seen with us voters show us that
the more authoritarian approach to
campaigning does appeal more to those
who are on the American right so while
both left and right can try this
it seems that right-wing American voters
are more likely to be drawn in by the
hyper authoritarianism it's it's it's a
it's to some extent true but what's
interesting to me is to see that there
had been people on the Left that have
followed left authoritarian leaders and
I think of you know one example I
mentioned in the book briefly was the
example of Jim Jones right and he really
wanted to have you know the the fantasy
state the socialist the pure socialist
Kingdom that he with him as the king and
we saw her that lit because people like
this become more and more paranoid and
dangerous what are the best ways to
expose individuals with these traits and
sort of refocus in reality what the
actual issues are and what the real
types of solutions we should be
considering are well I think first of
all I really want to see people become
aware of the HCP pattern so you see
somebody that's preoccupied with blaming
others has a lot of all-or-nothing
thinking and solutions unmanaged
emotions extreme behaviors people
oh that's an HCP and right now I can
tell you everybody listening to your
show knows somebody like that in their
personal life in the workplace the
neighborhood and and their families too
but that pattern isn't that hard to
recognize when you see it in leaders
that's when you see that it's going to
become dangerous but I think also that
voters volunteers candidates need to
really focus on providing as much
information as the HCPs provide emotion
and so when you get someone speaking 10
times as much as everybody else you need
to respond with that same amount of
information I call it the assertive
approach and it's worked in the legal
setting really for the last 25 years for
me and people that use this approach so
when they come out with emotions you
come out with information and match that
energy but not the destructive approach
that the HCPs use emotionally and I
think what a lot in our audience will
realize and it may even become apparent
in these upcoming very very large
20-person Democratic primary debates is
that that is not a technique that many
candidates are well suited for at a sort
of personal personality level so I think
it will be very very interesting to to
watch the book is called why we elect
narcissists and sociopaths and how we
can stop we've been speaking with the
books author Bill Eddy who's also the
co-founder and training director of the
high conflict Institute bill such a
pleasure speaking to you today thank you
so much David